48 hours after suffering a cardiac
arrest on the field encouraging news for
Buffalo Bill star Demar Hamlin welcome
to Entertainment Tonight you know it is
amazing to see how the NFL players and
the nation have rallied behind his
recovery to Mars family revealing the
latest on his condition today as we
learn more about the man behind the
rising football star
I cherish every second that I can you
know every second of every day Tamlin
made a hit he got up took a couple of
steps and then just fell to the ground
you never know when like the last day
could be that you getting a experience
something like this you know so I'm just
I'm cherishing at every moment I can
if not for what they did my nephew be
dead right now doctors are working to
get Demar to breathe on his own his
uncle Dorian Glenn says Demar was
receiving 100 of his oxygen from a
ventilator but now that's down to 50
percent the 24 year old who is in
critical condition is expected to remain
under intensive care we're all praying
for the best possible I'll come here it
was obviously a complicated situation on
the field that everybody was trying to
process they were prepared and gave
tomorrow the best chance
from Niagara Falls to downtown
Cincinnati fans are honoring the Buffalo
Bill's safety by lighting up landmarks
in the team's colors and demar's toy
drive with an original goal of 2500 is a
staggering success this morning
donations to his GoFundMe reached more
than six and a half million dollars it's
just a testament to how he lives his
life when you watched how people reacted
and when you watched the prayers it
tells you everything about this human
being I know he has our prayers and and
everyone's prayers and amidst prayers
for healing there is this controversy I
mean I cannot even get through a
monologue without you interrupting Fox
Sports Undisputed co-host Shannon sharp
and Skip Bayless argued about Skip's
tweet where he questioned how the league
could postpone a game of this magnitude
so late in the season I was under the
impression you weren't going to bring
this up because nobody here had a
problem with that tweet no clearly the
bosses wanted you to offer explanations
so clearly so no they did not now to to
another terrifying accident actor Jeremy
Renner bruised and battered but grateful
the 51 year old shared this selfie and
thanked fans from his hospital bed after
getting run over by his seven-ton snow
plow we believe this is a tragic
accident
Jeremy was in critical but stable
condition as of this morning he
reportedly underwent two separate
surgeries be my genuine pleasure turns
out Marvel's Hawkeye was sort of being a
superhero in real life he was being a
great neighbor and he was plowing those
roads for his neighbor because up there
they had three feet
[Music]